previously on making a mug club I wish I
could say that none of us saw this
coming but all of us for sure did you
know was in the cards for a lot of
people we've already been demonetised
quite a bit Heda monetizes his own
videos to sell more mugs in the era of
deep platforming it's becoming harder to
know who to trust before he completely
fabricated a conspiracy
I thought Owen Benjamin was a friend so
I couldn't make sense of why it would
spread what is clearly a lie because if
anyone would tell you who works with me
I'm an amazing person who's Steven yeah
he's alright so why would own lie like
that it didn't make sense furthermore
it's well known that he has the
attention span of a pomeranian so he
couldn't have woven this tapestry of
lies alone but who else on the right
would want to take down mug club it was
time to look at motive right away
the standout suspect was David Rubin who
is knowingly harbored ill will against
my mug club and it's tremendous success
for a long time catastrophic results
that we can't prove that yet people
don't agree on this you want to wait you
want to wait till Miami is supposed to
be gone Dave to most people it would
seem odd that David a gay guy would be
so angry but few people know that David
Rubin hides a far more sinister secret
it's a well-known fact that David Rubin
is a homosexual a disease which afflicts
less than 3% of a population causing him
to have unnatural sexual urges toward
other men it was a large part of his
brand for David Rubin though not as
bigger successful as mug Club being gay
was big business but what if he wasn't
telling the truth
what if gay David Rubin was hiding
something a rudimentary search of public
records revealed that David Rubin is in
fact married to a man and is indeed a
practicing homosexual but there's
something else that's been bothering me
something that doesn't add up
maybe I've been looking in the wrong
place no Dave Rubin is definitely gay
like no conspiracy definitely really
really gay I was real what are those
real it's a valid question what the hell
is wrong with you this kindness show is
a mistake you're not I don't
[Music]
[Music]
have you on the show today back in
studio was here yesterday and third
chair is Lauren southern Lauren
underscore southern how are you I'm good
wrong pronouns again remember legally a
man this is true so you don't have to be
uncomfortable anymore what's wrong do we
use a microphone yesterday Lauren for
those who missed you our mothers came in
a beautiful dress and we all felt
horrible and so he shamed her right away
and said yeah dress down yeah so we
pretty much chose we're in like PJs yes
exact time you're on the show we don't
have money for obvious reasons that guy
has a lot going on but we do have Karen
strong boom yeah we does stefan molyneux
we all set for a minister justin trudeau
and samantha bee again yeah not exactly
producing actually doing a really good
job this week is quarterblack geared you
are in fact a quarter black that's right
I am I appreciate it show the fans to
think no trust you that's terrible we're
gonna one who's the entire black on it's
all 4% and what's the one of the day add
you Morgan even had to bring an extra
large bottle for you heavy drinkers this
is a long shadows pirouette long shadows
pier why is it an extra-large Bob what
do they sell it in that placate when it
comes to wine size really does I feel
good something I would see on Pinterest
from a mom that I don't like wait this
is really good I am only having my one
serving of wine a day mommy needs or
special jus yes I ate for dinner yeah
yeah hopefully your kids have a pool
without a fence and hopefully you're
buying wine for me question of the day
we're gonna be talking quite a bit about
me too and some of the latest frauds
involved there of a few months into this
now I've seen a shift it notices shift
in the temperature change in the
temperature toward the movement so how
do you balance being supportive the
victims of course actual victims will
not automatically throwing anyone who's
ever been accused under the bus no
questions asked let me know let us know
we'll be talking about it and I think
we'll be talking about with with Karen's
Tron actually Lauren will be filling
hosting for me with Karen strong for
this just because I can
leading the news though you'll love this
Lauren I have no idea why is a new study
on eco sexuality did you know that was
the thing mm-hm so yeah having want to
know that was it what's happening to
like you're gonna tell me anyway I am
with the earth
yeah the earth taking the earth as a
lover
raises a number of legitimate concerns
regarding non-human consent as well as
sexualities comes from sage Journal -
the Lord seems like it would it seems
like this would raise a lot of questions
I've heard of objective sexuals like
that lady who married a flower
yes there's a natural trend now because
someone I guess a tree there people now
have been falling over 300 unstable well
that's what you say so this is the new
progressive frontier this is where we
are and we actually now go live to a
press conference being held by
representative from the other side of
the spectrum who disagrees them their
spokesperson is about to take the podium
thank you for coming I am appalled
that's a lack of compassion
self-awareness or accountability as it
relates to the ongoing sexual abuses of
my Trippel without consent largely
because they cannot consent this has
been an ongoing struggle which Trippel
americans sadly learn to live with but
with the recent events occurring at
Kevin Spacey's nursery and the widely
publicized herbicide of Harvey
Weinstein's potted ficus we can no
longer stay silent because that plant
had a name his name was ficus like this
morning would he was my friend
and for fear the ramifications to my
everlasting shame I stayed quiet but not
anymore
we will be silenced no more the tree -
movement is here to be heard and here to
stay I will now open the floor for any
questions you may have
yes I don't know what they were
expecting I know what Lauren was
expecting her face is something other
than what she's hearing I think you
should have known better Laurens are you
at a point that I've regretted coming
here since the moment I said yeah yeah
psychologize so so going back to
yesterday's conversation we're exactly
with the front hull B with a train on
the earth explained context for people
who don't I said going back to yesterday
nine dollars a year which is which is a
problem which is definitely a problem
stop doing the cervix okay Lauren to do
Gerald's job for him what's the context
of the front hole I have to be the one
to explain this yeah I get to explain
front hole what were privileged with the
task of explaining well friends I you
must know by now that using the proper
terms for genitals is a very offensive
thing to do because not everyone can
have vaginas so I thought you were gonna
avoid saying it I was going to and I
realized I couldn't I was my brain was
going it was like going through words
scrolling and I'm like no this was oh we
covered yesterday want us to call them
front holes yes yeah front holes and you
know what we're probably not gonna in
other news
Jon Stewart by the way came to the aid
of two goats from the run in Brooklyn
this comes to the New York Post the
comedian turned farmer rescued the two
row goats caught running around on the N
train tracks so the two go actually
taken to an upstate sanctuary where
they'll this is that is a feel-good
story they're gonna be taken care of
cared for well fed then groomed and
given a late-night talk show Donald
Trump is a piece of ba Michael Cohen can
suck my BA and I hope Bob I don't even
know which context those beliefs would
be necessary I know how it seems like
except when writing this program is
horribly confused between goats and
sheep or that's all we have the Wardrobe
for Thank You Lauren for tolerance by
the way hit the notification bell join
my pepper subscribe on iTunes if you
wanna listen to this audio on the go you
was a good man tebah I'm pleasantly
surprised gonna come back to haunt me it
will don't ever run for office that's
awesome but do up here in sharknado 5
that is actually I'll battle reverse
course for the only thing that makes me
feel better Coulter you and I now that's
significantly worse speaking of animals
by the way
a Chinese man was fine for release
pigeons on the highway if you're
wondering how could this go wrong let me
explain to you how so he told police
he'd been keeping 6070 pigeons but he
decided to set them free and he said he
chose the highway because it was a
wide-open space full of cars yeah didn't
know how this would end not exactly
about half of them survived but look
look let's not be too picky here this
does come from a country that eats dogs
so this is a step in the right direction
dogs and shiners at just Vietnam no it's
China that was the whole festival was in
China when we talked about it really yes
they have like an entire dog eating
festival another reason to not like them
and people get they inflate their
currency and they eat Mandy Fugees
have you ever seen those those posters
of vegans where they're like at which
point you side do you decide which ones
are food and they have a picture like a
cat dog pig cow everyone puts because
vegans are trying to say like they're
all beautiful animals but everyone just
puts the line before pig they turn junk
into bacon they're amazing vegans and
show them a fetal chart and watch them
explode like a fembot in Austin Powers
hey speaking of which I love you that
there's an all-female SWAT team well
yeah being deployed to protect the
Indian Prime Minister this comes from
msn.com they're expected to play a major
role in the security detail for the
Prime Minister's address and
Independence Day after being inducted by
the Delhi police
it just sounds funny Delhi police good
good not exactly the Hope Diamond but it
all female security to I know might seem
odd sorry about this one but we do try
to keep an open mind here lotos Crowder
handsome weather in the studio it's not
a little bit of tokenism so we decided
to look at the pros and cons in this
week's ion India
[Music]
[Applause]
so the pros and cons of an all-female
SWAT team yeah it'll be some pros there
are definitely some pros I know you you
thought this would this is not a
woman-hating club no no no we've been
pretty welcoming you know I hate when
truly I didn't get the memo oh just came
in just my only friends are gay men yes
it seems like you have a lot of gay male
friends yeah why they're the only people
that talk to me well that's questionable
with my wife she likes you
maybe she's a gay man have you even
yourself floor and that's all you need a
little secondly I I have asked in a
multitude of ways so there are some pros
for an all-female SWAT team in India up
pro for example the highly proficient in
the art of passive-aggressive dialogue
huh very useful on the bits mental
warfare another Pro they're 23 percent
more cost-effective oh yeah with a
percent more cost-effective another pro
this long-distance swimming yeah okay a
lot of people didn't know that you
didn't know that no I know that
long-distance swimming do you know that
women are better at longest in swimming
how do you not know this it's the one
physical thing you are better at than me
and you it's the only thing the only
thing as far as a sport yeah they're
like better they're better than men at
long-distance swimming women are
actually I I didn't I didn't know it I
don't know if like if I put this way if
women were better at almost all the
sports than men and then we had one
thing like we would be clinging to that
I guess you just have healthier egos
cons of course cons an all-female SWAT
team vulnerable when cold and the unit's
forget their jackets
that's one yeah that definitely is
chilly next con unit often incapable of
being able to even mm-hmm you know it
seems a little odd in the middle on the
battle for putting them at the front
lines another con unit available there
M'Vila before - six days out of the
month that seems obvious we can move on
another con pull ups
yeah pull ups is right there and the
final con is every other physical
activity unfortunate for an all-female
team outside of long-distance swimming
outside of long I mean it's just like a
water attack their goal
right but I could say sharks sharks you
gotta save the Prime Minister from sharp
sharks what is he doing I don't know I
don't Kenny not Canadians not swim or
you know I didn't say that oh you're
putting words in my mouth now well let's
see we've offended the Chinese Indians
we got time to offend everybody else
don't worry look here's the thing I say
go for it like if this guy gets
assassinated it's his own damn fault at
this point if he actually fix it all
female crew go for it prove the model
exactly he didn't have the foresight
maybe it's a trade-off he's like nice
view oh my I'll take the coin toss is
just Bollywood film star yeah before he
dies finally a Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau is now defending his
recent racist attack he I guess his he
called this heckler racist you know what
let's just before let's just roll this
clip right here and I'll explain to you
that's what that's what my entire
maternal family ever sounds like I'm on
my whole mom's side
I met them he's right yeah they always
sound wrong there you go so she's asking
them about about the refugees costing
hundreds of billions of dollars to the
taxpayer and here you go here he is he's
saying this racism plays no role in
Quebec now do you speak you don't speak
French do you know okay all right so
that was just as I was trying to Tran
she's basically saying hey what about
the cost of the asylum seekers and
refugees and he just says yeah you're a
racist
it's extremely frustrating because
you've also got the media and just the
progressive education system supporting
this and saying yes it's a racist view
to ask about taxpayers money being
wasted on illegal migrants it's a racist
view to have borders it's a racist
extremist view to want to have a
nation-state with an identity that is
completely false the extremest opinion
is Trudeau's opinion to destroy borders
to destroy a national identity if you
don't have those things you're not a
country so why are we pretending women
like this who are asking rational
questions are the extremists
it's a lot harder for Canada to because
I'm like the United States where our
identity was basically a series of ideas
Canada's identity was sort of you know
kissing the ring of the Queen it was an
app calling it was right it was a colony
that's the United States identity was
never racially tinged right it was
entirely constitutionally based people
don't understand that in Canada or
inland places like Germany for them it
was a people and so yeah it's a little
bit of a tougher transition yeah well
absolutely she said it right so this
woman actually said illegal immigrants
in her question he and originally
responded from the podium but she said
did he replied with immigrants your your
hostility towards immigrants has no
place here and then later on said the
racism immediately changed it back to
the word immigrants aren't a race
exactly
and yet illegal illegal people are
different yeah and we were talking about
this yesterday you said they get all
kinds of benefits when they go there
they get picked up and taken like a
valet service to a hotel for the only
two years of welfare like they are
heading more money than Canadians and
Canadians are paying for this of
Canadians that are struggling there on
the streets we have literally hundreds
of thousands of kids in Canada that are
below the poverty line and you're
bringing in tons of illegals from
America thanks by the way yes I know
we're sending him north I don't know we
should say would you just send them all
to Mexico you know what you want to come
there or said them all to Quebec like
French sounds kind of sexy right but
people they think of French people oh I
like say Marge M definitely Oh nuts you
head you know that's that's what French
Canada sounds like like ordering
potatoes European French should be like
je vous de pommes de terre Zulu play
button Quebec Abby that's actually what
they sound like I'm not even saying
words you understand but you think you
hear they drunk at this point is that
normal but here to give his what do we
have them here to give his side of the
story actually is Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau Prime Minister
are you there sir thanks for having me
Stephen now Prime Minister you were
recently criticized firstly for racism
in Canada I didn't ask my question I'm
sorry sorry reflexes please continue
you were recently criticized for how you
responded to a constituent during us
speech she was yelling hate speech but
the question was when the federal
government would repay Quebec for the
cost that it's incurred as a result of
the influx of illegal immigrants coming
across a canadian-us border that was the
question that she asked right hate
speech yeah how exactly is that hate
speech well I I really hate it when
people yell questions at me it actually
seems like a reasonable question Prime
Minister yeah I have to see exactly what
she said actually quarter person of
color Garrett can you roll clip see he
doesn't get to ask you that no you don't
get to ask him that I'm not of this show
you're not what about the question
though do you think that loose
immigration laws and incentives for
asylum seekers have added to your one
point four trillion dollar deficit maybe
you you know as well as I do Stephen the
deficits are not an indicator of
long-term economic viability but Prime
Minister Harper ran a surplus four years
off the backs of our First Nations
people Stephen what was what was that I
don't know what's we thought seems like
a constant ooh
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau everybody
that's not going anywhere good I still
can't believe you got the Prime Minister
on I know I know
I also can't believe we got a raped tree
yeah that was a very good get you know I
mean I think you know that he is who he
is right and offensive to you that
Justin Trudeau I've accepted it I just I
don't talk about Canada no you know it's
Canada and no I
they have no idea how good they had it
with Harper they really don't understand
how well the housing crisis was largely
avoided because of his policies and they
just never appreciated him it's much
like the Northern Europeans they get
this like kind of socialism and this
diversity this beautiful utopian mindset
because they have all of these other
countries protecting them from
third-world mass immigration we have
America protecting us we don't need an
army we don't need to worry about the
Mexican board
we have water in America so we think
look at our perfect country you dummies
we don't have to do it immigrants but
also bombs Rockets yeah you guys would
have you guys would have a snowball's
chance in hell against rockets you know
if it's a choose your own path book it's
like okay get screwed let me pass B C
path a still get screwed we hate America
so much when I was growing up in school
I used to just tell kids I was American
just oh my god they would get ya they
all hate Americans but as soon as things
get rough Oh America where'd you go yes
I know you guys have Omaha Beach and the
ones but can we just get Juno Juno
sounds good I just walk onto that one
right by the way of course Canada really
helped us in World War two I'm not
[ __ ] at all but do you we actually
used to watch footage I'd seen Saving
Private Ryan the film obviously in right
suit oh my god and then I watched actual
footage in school of Juno Beach and they
actually get off get off the book that
the pontoon boats and they run into the
mist
to the poem like well they got up there
they got pretty far they don't even need
Barry Pepper no it was pretty easy for
them I mean just be honest so anyway
let's move on to the let's move on to
the me to move in here recently two
prominent sexual harassment cases so
involving women abusing men at surface
the other way around
yes happen no I haven't be silly well it
does happen every now and then but
usually the guy gets high-fived that's a
[ __ ] that's the secret we don't let you
in ah so first and I want your
pronouncement is Asya are jaz-o you know
when it's spelled like I'm gonna say
Asia and I know it's I think it's mine
why no I'm gonna go rape I got eccentric
para mom so the first one this is why
we're asking you where you line up on
sort of what are the dividing line is
and it's different for everyone you want
to believe people of course you want to
come to the aid and protect women who
have been victimized yeah but you also
don't want to ruin people's lives so
first it was a hacia Argento she was one
of the original leaders of the me tube
movement yeah yeah with her I think she
brought forth right through
rape accusations against Weinstein yeah
yeah she was one of the first people so
now that's been exposed that she was
having sex with a minor she knew and she
dreamed this kind of a Hollywood mom
since he was here's the thing with the
story there's no easy way to treat it's
not like oh well my minor but a Japan 7
years old
I think that's below everyone's cut off
a little bit yeah I mean even Mohammed
would like Jesus that's kind of harsh
I can't submit it when she was nine oh
my gosh you know when you offend that
guy
hold your camels before i sexually
accost
them but not before seven Mohammed I did
I did send your letters so she then by
the way issued she she she paid three
hundred and eighty thousand dollars in
hush money to keep him quiet don't take
my word for it
Asya Argento paid three hundred eighty
thousand dollars to a young man and he
is claiming that our Gento sexually
assaulted him in 2013 at a california
hotel so it's official
in case you were wondering yeah I also
had it wrong did you hear it's hacia I
see I see I see yeah I see yeah yeah how
could how do we get it there's there's
only three syllables and we've got some
all we got three of them wrong it's all
her fault and her parents direct was uh
you know it was shocking about this that
CNN actually covered it
that's what surprised me the most very
briefly very briefly and they do it the
right way but they at least had a know
then another one it's important was a
hobbit towel I think rock Rennell is
that is how it's pronounced again I
don't know I don't want to try an
academic who teaches German and
comparative literature at NYU so even
though here's what's interesting about
this do you know the story behind this
person I see yeah as you know no we the
next day we moved other avatar hahahaha
I was the one who bit the bullet because
none of us knew how to pronounce it we
all realize we read the news because we
don't really watch or listen to it
because we try to actually keep her I
try to not contaminate my mind with what
Don Lemon has to say or anyone who's I
try to read it that way it's kind but
then I forget how to pronounce
mispronounce it and go with it I think
when you try to pronounce it correctly
well screwed yours okay let me clarify
for you even though she was supposedly a
lesbian she sexually harassed twist a
gay male graduate soon is that like a
double negative positive
yeah well this comes from the
conservative screams in New York time
so hobbit al Rennell then he said she
pulled him into her bed she put my hands
onto her breasts and was pressing
herself her buttocks onto my crotch
he said she was kissing me kissing my
hands kissing my torso that evening a
similar scene played out again he said
and you know that's a gay man just by
his description right yeah Oh sounds
like sounds like a a regular night it
sounds like it did like your fantasy
night and then let's just be honest
grasping her Your Honor may the record
state that the professor was twerking
official term and yes he's really gay
because he didn't like it at all here's
the not one not one hey if you see
pictures he might not be good okay it
might just be brilliant cover at this
point
nice no what were these people
excoriated for it like everyone else in
the me to it no no no no no what do you
think happened with them mm-hmm could it
be you're not used to moving your chin
dear you have to pretend like you have a
chin beard yeah okay yeah there you go
think Jafar you got it Jafar that
happened
they were defended in hours by the left
yeah why not they even received a letter
defending yeah yeah but both both of
them actually sigh signed by a squad of
famous academics including Judith Butler
you've heard us talk about of the month
mother of all gender studies Judith
Butler that's the one these tree
offending them the first one to say that
gender was a spectrum was Judah gentler
even before modern gender theory it was
still kind of like with transgenders or
transsexuals there were two genders you
could swap Judith Butler was the one who
said she's the one I thought this is
what's so infuriating about this whole
Hollywood mess is now that it's like
blown up with sexual assault accusations
against everyone every gender every
group they're suddenly saying the things
that conservatives were saying years and
years ago which is assault accusations
are complicated you need to make sure
you have all the facts before you
persecute someone send someone to jail
or ruin their life and it's horrible to
rape someone
no conservatives ever said great to rape
someone they've always thought it was
bad they've just thought let's get the
facts yeah now suddenly you have Rose
McGowan freaking out and saying oh my
friends been accused yeah let's be
gentle exams let's be careful it's like
okay no exactly all of a sudden we're a
little hazy on the rules here usually
every server they all need to be
believing now I don't know where we line
up yeah it's exactly what seeing ended
that's how they get it wrong they strike
the entire segment talking about where
they got the documents from and well
we're not really sure and we got it from
here but they didn't speak about the the
terrible nature of what she actually did
yeah they spent the whole time kind of
schedule around exactly you know but I
think I think there's and I think that's
important to ring up there are two kind
of sides to this meeting movement
there's exposing perverts the Kevin
Spacey's of the road Harvey Weinstein's
granted yeah and and holding them
accountable absolutely I think we should
do more of that uh no sir little
castration in there I'm fine you've
actually done it just that's your man I
feel men with wives or mothers or
daughters we don't have a secret meeting
behind your backs to be like not
secretly they like raping all of them it
never happens no no I've never once had
a guy bring up rape in front of me
outside of the context of a joke because
if there's nothing else that we've
learned from the show
it's that rape is always funny the
second side me too movement and be
monetized no I'm quarterblack hit the
show Laura she was laughing at that but
are they are hide herself that sort of
pass she's our nether region pass to
quote her I love the trunk front hole I
remember cornered yourself into saying
so many words in my brain come up
completely empty there's no good word
for me I mean it's like with guys like
tallywacker pecker John Thomas and all
kind of silly but with women they're all
gonna be sexualized like there aren't a
lot of silly name vagina is almost the
most polite word so there's the flip
side of course it's just too wet to
weaponize it right yeah a couple of
examples here so the case of Argentan or
Nell they reveal that this crowd like
you see they don't believe their own
press and remember here's a clip of none
other than Hillary Clinton telling you
what you should do with anyone who comes
forward when it comes to accusations of
rape you have a right to be heard and
you have a right to be believed I know
you thought that clip might be longer
that's it Hillary Clinton yeah really
she's the one that means
after you and I have a right to be
believed you know it's funny I would
much sooner believe you saying it than
anyone else in this room said that's
true yeah well look with the Urban Meyer
story I mean that's a big topic right
now I was I was really afraid for the
guy because I played for him at Notre
Dame
he was an unbelievable coach but
everybody immediately was saying this is
the end of his career yeah done and he'd
it wasn't even the guy involved in the
situation
well like I understand that maybe he
didn't do everything exactly right but
immediately people are like he's done
he's out I was so pissed off so thank
goodness it was a three game since and
doesn't kind of screwed the pooch on
that one though so for the rest of all
time it was what Myer wasn't doing
studio okay look it's not exactly the
worst word we've said on air today okay
worthy I regretted my date with Aziz
Ansari article do you member that did
you ever read that yes I feel like that
was the end of the me to kind of cult
following and that being said I hate him
I think he's an ass as he's I'm sorry I
do not like him he's a huge arrogant
liberal ungrateful immigrant ass but
they try to destroy his career over
something with very little evidence and
this is what it's it's it's not about
bringing perpetrators to justice no it's
become in large part about demonizing
men so when the me to movement first
broke remember it wasn't really about
Weinstein immediately they just use it
as a springboard
it wasn't about blaming individuals they
blamed what toxic masculinity
all right cool that was yeah I think we
even have an overlay here from CNN yep
okay anyone now yelling about toxic fake
lesbian entity but I repeat myself well
what happens when it's a lesbian sexual
raping a gay guy yeah we don't even have
a file for that I'm not sure what we do
with it your guess is as good as mine
the system has to change because the guy
so in in these situations the guy has
zero recourse once it's out there that
you sexually assaulted somebody even if
it's not true you can't unring the bell
yeah even if these people like you what
can you do after that your name is
ruined forever
even if an article gets published saying
you didn't do it you're still that guy
who was accused of rape or sexual
that'll never be justice for Kevin
Spacey
obviously a problem in Hollywood like
yes there are these ridiculous me to
claims in there just as much of a
problem with the lying and everything
but sex is a powerful thing and this is
what people have they've tried to make
it seem like oh you can sleep with
anyone and it's no problem at all Cosmo
says it's liberating I'm Jordan Pederson
out of interesting analysis when me too
started he said this is finally going to
teach our generation like this is
something that really psychologically
influences people this is something that
endowments a society and you need to
respect it
you guys need to stop being so crazy and
ridiculous with it and this is what's
happened Hollywood is in shambles
because of this one thing that the
liberal media tries to tell us is so
free and liberating and anyone can do it
all the time I mean on the show because
a lot of people and I was still would
welcome her back on the show but I won't
kind of gave her a they gave her a Hall
Pass yeah and she was just saying well
you know in case you don't realize women
like to get laid and I said I'm not
saying that some women don't like to get
laid what I am saying is that I believe
that women by and large not all women
we're making a generalization are not as
sexually predatorial as men it's like
well disagree fine common ground with
that right do you think women want to
have sex with as many men as human coz
that is what all men here if everyone
gay guy it's being honest here with no
moral compass sex with as many women as
you possibly could yeah everyone else
but I have a no I know I'm absolute
saying but women are you that way women
I even if they are tricked by media
whatever it may be schooling to think
you can do whatever you want I think
deep down they know because at the end
of the day after they've been with a guy
and the guy says goodbye after tinder
even if they both agreed to just do a
Netflix and chill they're sad they call
up their girlfriends I've had girls call
me after this and they're upset about it
and they like I don't understand why I'm
upset I don't understand why I'm
attached to this guy I only met him once
well how far did you go right because
that it's literally psychologically
wired in your body to make those
connections yeah the bond with people is
Christian to talk there's kind of like a
there's a soul tie that occurs you were
you're about say some in their
quarterblack yeah I had a friend that
did the same thing that he went on a
tinder date and you know things happen
and he felt bad after it
I mean just just like that yeah it's
fermented everybody rare for a guy a guy
with no sir no I do yeah I I do listen
and that thing's I guess because of the
moral compass component that being said
guys are hardwired to spread there see
it's a goalpost moving power grab from
the progressive left that's the one by
the way it's one that ultimately hurts
both sexes certainly women take henry
cavill for example he said it was afraid
to date in the me to hero right and then
feminists jumped on him and said
feminists and bernie sanders Superman
just as one of his subject of a Rolling
Stone article that's it have you met
powers weakening is a kryptonite
no it's mattress girl you have nothing
to fear if you're not a rapist you have
everything to fear if you have a penis
dating was hard enough when you didn't
have to have written consent before yes
kiss to someone right well that's what
they've been difficult for charities to
separately funded by the way
progressives haven't made it to me too
moving is less about true than it is
about causing what they quote a shift in
power imbalances yeah that's from the
conversation right there a shift in
power imbalances and that's everything
that's black that'll be the closing
closing segment I want to talk about
that a little bit more because shifting
power and balance is just for the sake
of it you have to figure out who's at
the other end of that seesaw when you
shift it that's really important to know
and this is foundational for the modern
progressive left like we've talked about
it's the underdog automatically has the
moral high ground and I'm like here we
have to get going left to get going to a
stefan molyneux here ii unlike john
oliver samantha be here Samantha but or
Trevor Noah who just [ __ ] I do want to
be solution-oriented and you touched on
this and I think you're right the
problem we're told is we have a culture
of rape okay let's go along with that
premise what's the fix the solution is
the exact same kind of crap that you've
been mocking for decades like my pet not
Mike Pence not going out to dinner alone
the woman who's not his wife like not
allowing your teenage daughter or son to
go upstairs or the door closed in a box
of Trojans how about that maybe teaching
young people that abstinence if not
until marriage which I still advocate
that's just a personal decision it's
just me but at least until you're old
enough and in a permanent relationship
or a long-term relationship maybe that
could be beneficial
like maybe teaching young men to serve
and protect young women by holding doors
for them by not allowing them in a
dangerous situation
and yes that includes the frontlines of
war why because pull-ups like teaching
women that motherhood is more important
than your business success why so they
can race successful morally upright
young men and women of their own maybe
like teaching men yeah
man you don't get off the hook about
real masculinity let's throw in terms
toxic masculine how about just real
masculinity like being a leader a good
husband a faithful husband and a father
who stays with mommy and works through
the marital problems even though his
feelings might be hurt how about that
what you call toxic masculinity I call
necessary for the survival of the human
species and you know it's not you know
it's not necessary for the survival of
the human species identity politics
toxic lesbianism lesbian in an in an ism
I don't remember I don't even know what
you call toxic lesbian raping gay
student ism and man shaming that's not
necessary for the preservation of the
human species dummies love stefan
molyneux after this and then morons
gonna interview Karen that mean that'll
be fun on now for hopper proverbs
sponsored exclusively by mud club they
said that if you give a dog some cheated
you feed him for a day but if you give a
dog a cow I don't well I don't know how
to make Chili's but if I diversify some
thumbs a Papa could figure it out just
on my club so Steven can give Harper
more teasers because he has thumbs
stay tuned for more hopper proverbs
sponsored by mug club
[Music]
all right very glad to have our next
guest actually Lauren is not here right
now she had to use a restroom which
actually ties in perfectly we're gonna
leave this conversation off with
restroom talk you know I'm of course
youtube.com slash free domain radio as
long as they allow him and I want to get
this plug right he's speaking at phyllis
schlafly 'z gateway eagle council st.
louis missouri september 13th through
16th of course you see is twitter there
stefan molyneux stefan molyneux did i
get that right and that's that's great
i'm actually looking forward to the
Eagle Forum I pretty much assume that
they're gonna release a rabbit on the
stage and I'm gonna drop to it on the
rafters that's the whole approach my
speech is basically gonna be that's
generally the plan so you know you have
to be there or you'll miss the whole
experience is that an honor Phyllis
Schlafly no just the name eagle no I
like to feel that she I had her on the
show a couple of times she died of
course quite recently at the ripe old
age of 90 something yeah
and yeah a very powerful great woman she
did a lot of great stuff Polly
politically she was a mother of the year
for her entire state she raised six kids
yeah quite a powerful force in nature
that woman a lot to admire she actually
good sense of humor I had to introduce
her at CPAC one year so there were about
four years in a row where I was this
emcee at CPAC and then I ended up just
hating my life so I stopped but I
introduced Sarah Palin and I mentioned
you know okay former governor of Alaska
and I said and she's fine and people
kind of laughed and then I brought up
Phyllis Schlafly and the very last thing
I said about her wasn't and I should
also mention that she's fine and she can
actually is like a funny young gentleman
I don't think she realized the sexual
connotations you were saying before on
air that you really enjoy speaking daddy
like were your words yeah so I mean for
a variety of reasons not least of which
being a stay-at-home dad to a toddler
but I didn't do much on the road for
like half a decade and going back out
with Lauren to Australia and well almost
New Zealand was fantastic I really
remember just how much fun it is to play
with an audience and and of course the
audience is in Australia quite
interactive and and that was a lot of
fun the QAR a lot of blacks I think I'm
sorry I said you mean they're a lot of
black people in Australia like I see I
invite them to be part of the show
because you got to give them something
they're not going to
yet by just clicking on a YouTube so I
want that interactivity and I want to
play back and forth so Oh remembering
how much I like it um I'm available for
children's parties bar mitzvahs the
usual and you know people want me to
come and speak
oh oh I'll do it I'll do it so yeah
that's why I'm doing the Eagle Forum and
got some other stuff lined up as well
because man is it ever fun being out in
front of an audience again I am the eggs
I hate it I despise it I've we were
talked about I've never liked it
I feel very I feel like I have to do it
because people want to want to come out
and see us live and I'm very
appreciative of the fans but I was a kid
who before an oral it would feel like I
I would get the same kind of bandy bandy
leg and it's like Bambi's mom before I
would go out to jujitsu matches or any
kind of a sporting of it I would get so
nervous and I remember feeling like I
was gonna throw up but I don't throw up
I almost never throw up so just get
explosive excrement before every oral
when I was a kid I don't know why I
started doing stand-up comedy I always
get nervous before audiences I envy
people like you who don't get the nerves
no no no see it's not that I don't get
the nerves I do but it's more excitement
but my big fear well there's two big
fears when it comes to public speaking
especially when you're doing like some
big huge area with a very ill-defined
stage edge like you don't want to do a
full you know Steve Tyler and plunge
right off the stage and hope that
someone catches you so I actually like
getting there earlier making friends
with the space and making sure I know
where the edge is because they never
tape it and it's just like good luck
hoping I'll plunge somewhere and the
other is I have this nightmare that
halfway through a speech because I do
like an hour are usually on more halfway
through a speech I'm just gonna have to
pee yeah and it's gonna come on like a
tsunami you know and then all I'm gonna
see is people drinking water and all
that kinda stuff it's like when I want
to go and see the movie Titanic and I
had one of these giant float drinks in
the entire last half of the movie is
people sloshing around in water didn't
want this anything I thought that's
gotta be over soon no it doesn't because
it's the movie Titanic it takes actually
less time for the ship to sink them for
the movie to end but yeah those my only
two big fears and you can deal with one
by making friends with the space and you
can deal with the other by having four
pigs before you go bad to speak so after
hearing that anecdote uh what I what I
glean from it is stefan molyneux 'he's
gay yeah he went to Titanic and was
actually afraid to miss
a portion of the taken I was looking for
a reason for a bathroom break
I can't miss jack not for one moment you
can't take his eyes off of Daniel no III
do Isis back Wendy I know this is Mac
when you would roll the dice and you've
got at least a 75 25 split on seeing
Kate's boobs in a movie right because
she was just like this was her audition
was just like flaming yeah you know this
is back in the day when the internet was
still pretty primitive and it was worth
paying 12 bucks to go see some boobs
Heather Graham it was in her contract
for every single film it wasn't a 70/30
split it was just it was a there's no
rolling of the dice it was really just
you were just like throwing a ball just
throwing Superman I need some pants that
are basically made from a headband and
rollerskates won't hurt but that's
basically how I roll that's pretty much
how it goes so but I know we were just
talking about Lauren and how you've been
touring and you have more speaking
engagements coming up I highly recommend
people go go check it out but let's talk
about this also you're you're almost
gone from YouTube I mean I say that you
probably you won't be and we'll
obviously be here to hopefully help you
in whatever capacity we can and people
can find out where to support you I'm
sure you can tell them but yeah how many
hard strikes did you get immediately
after Joan Alex Jones was a two right in
a row well it was actually immediately
after coming back from Australia you
know we're still trying to tunnel
through that Gollum like jet lag that
happens and basically yeah I mean it was
a real drive by you know it's like that
samuel l.jackson character in Pulp
Fiction you know bang bang bang and it's
just his outlines on the wall behind you
because we got to community guideline
strikes for like I don't know
offensively inappropriate content or
however they exactly phrase it and yeah
it was pretty rough and one of them was
on an interview I did with Katie Hopkins
noted British journalist and the other
was me talking about how white males
were dying in the opioid crisis in
particular so apparently whole that's
hateful
but you know kudos to YouTube kudos to
the community who fired off thousands of
lovely delightful positive and warm
messages saying hey dudes not fair back
the hell off this is an injustice and
they were taken off the account and of
course note there's never any
communication you got to read the tea
leaves you gotta you know just write yes
what's going on but yeah there was no
chicken bone of the toilets you know it
really
somebody did the old mass flag and I
guess somebody in YouTube thought it was
bad and I guess it went to a higher
level of review and you know I mean I've
never had any problems you know 12 years
been on YouTube I was like I was like
user number four right YouTube and
twelve years no problems you go on a
tour you ruffle some feathers and boom
boom boom yeah you get all of this stuff
but you know this is the kind of
blowback you naturally get when you're
over the top they were about to give you
your walking papers like Jack Lemmon and
Glengarry Glen Ross sending you out into
the rain it was really I was I was when
I heard about it at first I was really
worried and sad but I thought this will
probably be rectified but I do
appreciate YouTube it's for closers
u2 is for closers only put that video
down I do think and something I admire
about you and something that we try to
draw attention to listen we have we have
the ability to reach the highest legal
counsel with at YouTube ish they don't
always respond because of my half-asian
lawyer bill Richmond on retainer and
because of the fact that we found them
and we made contact with them so then
it's even more damning if they don't
respond but what worries me is not what
they're doing to you or to myself
because we know there's enough blowback
we're so we can hold them somewhat
accountable but the next guys coming up
behind us the people with the smaller
channels there are so many stories that
we may never even know including you and
myself because her inboxes get flooded
and we don't have the time to check all
of them every day that's the kind of
thing that keeps me up at night well
you're absolutely right I mean there are
the people who are they up in commerce
and I get messages just like you if
people saying well you know I did I had
a channel I was doing it for six months
it was growing and then boom boom boom
it got vanished and this happens the
Facebook pages this happens on YouTube
and other places and you know much
though I'd love to help everyone you
know we've we've got lives and audiences
to please and all that so yeah there's a
lot of people out there who are not with
the kind of size and reach and clout
that we have and they're getting
disappeared and don't have the
scientific the same kind of recourse and
that is a real shame because I want the
new talent to emerge I strongly
encourage people to take the swing at
trying to affect people positively in
the cultural wars I try and encourage
young talent as much the more the more
competition the better I don't know why
CNN wants the wipeout competition you
know that's a great challenge to get
better you know what why do you want to
wipe out competition they polish you to
a shine
yeah well I don't think you can polish
down lemon to a shine it's always a
matte finish at this point it's just
like the matte finish of near-death that
is always there's a lemon pledge joke in
there somewhere
phew looks like dead Johnny Mathis if
Johnny Mathis returned from the grave it
would look like Don Lemon you could use
a stand-in and I do hope listen people
out there obviously reach as many of the
big youtubers as you can if your channel
is removed we always tell people
obviously Stefan you know this because
sometimes we'll get messages like okay I
just ran an entire like we're talking I
just uploaded Glengarry Glen Ross to my
entire YouTube channel you could do it's
like hold on a second most of the time
you usually are violating copyright but
if you're in the right you know that
you're not you know you're doing the
right things ya do reach out to as many
people as possible sometimes I don't get
through but we do want to help you guys
really quickly we don't have a ton of
time we have Karen strong coming up that
I think actually Lauren is going to fill
in hosts for me we'll see how that goes
mom your recent video was titled the end
of South Africa I believe and I know you
just toured with Lauren southern who did
farmlands and that we were talking about
that documentary well what do you think
happens obviously the title is
provocative people can go watch it but
how do you think this all comes down in
in South Africa how do you think it ends
well I mean I I hate to think that it's
inevitable and the title is provocative
because I don't want it to be the end of
South Africa right I want people to have
enough food I want them to have
political fruit so I don't want the
government bunging in with guns to strip
land from people who've been farming it
for generations right so as you know
they changed the constitution recently
to allow for the communist takeover of
arms and it's like how many times do we
have to see this damn story play out in
human history of the last hundred and
fifty years it's like all these people
are doing really really well
that's injustice that's bigotry that's
races and we're gonna redistribute all
of their stuff and then everybody gets
to starve to death and fewer than 1% of
South Africans of any race care about
this land at issue it's just something
that's held up to excuse bad behavior
and corruption in government it's it's
the equivalent of the Russia collusion
story to explain why Hillary lost the
election it's like well the reason that
the economy is doing so badly the reason
that South Africa is no longer a net
food exporter but a net food importer
the reason why the rand is crashing
against the dollar it's because there
are too many white farmers is like no
it's
not because of that it's because the
government is horribly corrupt and
inefficient and they have really racist
laws that are there to promote a lot of
blanks getting into jobs to keep whites
out of jobs it's because they have these
massive squatter camps full of whites
who are not allowed to work it's a
really horrible system they need to fix
the system but they've had the rod of
communism in there for decades starting
before even the ANC and Mandela got into
power and if we can find a way to push
back against this communist takeover
fantastic if we can't well they go in
the way of the Khmer Rouge in Cambodia
they go in the way of the Communists
takeover in in Mao's China and in the
Holodomor in Ukraine everyone's gonna
starve and then everyone's gonna be
sitting there saying wow we gotta help
all these people and it's like I gotta
tell you from what I'm seeing man
there's a lot of compassion fatigue
about this because you know if it's a
drought that's one thing but if you're
starving case you nationalized the farms
and stole from everyone sympathy not
massively high and that's gonna be
horrible to see it's hard to get the gap
to do a campaign for that
I thought tourism had just died out
there because of Leonardo DiCaprio's
horrible accent and Blood Diamond but
that'll do damage to a country's
reputation we do have to get going I do
encourage people to go watch it and let
me to make sure Phyllis Schlafly is
gateway Eagle Council in st. Louis
September 13th through 16th of course
youtube.com slash freedomain radio
Stefon thank you for being here sir we
have to go see Karen strong
all right there library time first live
read of the weekend the last library we
only do one live read a week ladder with
credit.com /mo club that's what keeps
this show going lauren has been here
actually a few days this week for those
who don't see the daily shades it's 45
minutes you know every single day and
you get the clips on YouTube 69 dollars
annually for students veteran or active
military and it's what allows us to do
not only the show but go on location do
the hidden camera work do the
investigative work and we appreciate so
much the people who've joined up
especially with YouTube right now in the
instability we really are doing a lot
better because so many fans have joined
up and supported and we're growing and
we're moving into a new place and we're
going to be confronting more people more
change my minds
next week is razörfist bringing in
supporting the people who stuck their
neck outs for us so we appreciate any
support you don't have to you can watch
the free stuff but it might go away if
not enough you do you know that
[Music]
nice so good at dancing hello everyone
and welcome to louder with Lauren and
today we are with the wonderful
beautiful Karen strong from girl rights
what and honey badger radio on YouTube
Karen and I actually haven't seen each
other since we went to a [ __ ] walk
together in Alberta I think was it yeah
it was in Edmonton here you got to sleep
on my couch which probably wasn't fun no
it was a very very cozy couch now I
understand that you wanted to talk about
the aja aja can't pronounce her name
Argento situation
one of the first accusers of Harvey
Weinstein and one of the founders of the
me2 movement and you want to talk about
the fact that she has just been accused
herself of statutory rape
with one of her co-stars actually a
younger male it's it's a little bit of a
weird story like I think the the
statutory rape thing kind of muddies the
waters because I mean everybody knows
that there are 17 year olds out there
who are capable of caen consenting to
sex right in Canada or age of consent is
16 but what really struck me about this
particular case is is that they met on
set when he was 7 years old or something
like that and they have had this they
formed a bond that they both described
kind of it like a mother-son bond and
she's still calling him her son and you
know like her Sonny Boy and all this I
don't think that's one situation you
know the French president with his his
much older or wife that used to be his
teacher and they've got this weird like
mommy's son creepy roleplay thing going
on yeah well and and he describes the
situation as something that wreck
actually really messed him up so
essentially and she was 37 and he was 17
so that's like a significant age
difference there then you factor in the
relationship between them that that
might mess somebody up and as the
responsible adult in the room she
probably should have you know even if he
was interested she should have said no
no this is not okay but how the age
itself being under the age of consent
just confuses the real weirdness of this
situation right right and and TMZ has
come out with the photos of them now in
bed together so there were some doubts
now people are a little more kind of
sure that this did happen what do you
make of Rose McGowan's comment so she
came out and said everyone needs to hold
their judgment and be gentle towards
Asia Argento well I think that people
should withhold their judgement for sure
until evidence but that's not how
dominating anyone else in Hollywood was
it or anywhere in general McGowan was
saying yesterday we've all victims
believe all victims unless they're men
yeah no that's that's absolutely the the
problem or unless who they're accusing
is a woman that that's the issue that I
have is like I would argue in favor of
Rose McGowan's approach to this case
that that should be the approach to
every case but that's not what the me to
movement is arguing you know I believe
survivors I believe victims every
acquittal is is a miscarriage of justice
right every man who comes out with
evidence you know or every time
something like the University of
Virginia you know rolling stone false
accusation comes out as false and is
discredited that that's actually proof
of somebody getting away with it
somewhere so the whole thing is just
annoying and and it's frustrating and
it's hypocritical the Hollywood is a
mess I can't even look at it anymore it
upsets me their lives are all just they
need to sort that out now something else
that is a mess and you talk about it a
lot on a honey badger Radio Free Speech
situation of
famed internet provocateur Count de
aquila who taught his pug dog how to do
the Nazi salute and was brought up on
hate speech charges in the UK has now
lost his case and subsequent appeal and
he is trying to take the case to the UK
Supreme Court for a final appeal to see
if he has the right to make a joke
without being prosecuted essentially
your thoughts my thoughts you know like
when you when you watch the video and I
did watch the video and I found it
hilarious and played it for my kids and
they found it hilarious
is your dog also at Baptist sorry is
your dog also a fascist my dog is I
would say she's borderline personality
and it's called disorder but she's not
hot it's not extremely political
essentially he said he prefaced the joke
with to play a prank on my girlfriend
I'm gonna turn her cute wee dog into the
least cute thing I can think of which is
of course a Nazi right so thinking of
the worst possible thing I could turn
this dog into which would indicate that
he doesn't like Nazis the guy oddly also
this is something that the mainstream
media never mentions he has a giant
tattoo on his chest of a hammer and a
sickle that's something that I
conveniently forgets when they discussed
this case I don't think that he's I
think his political views have changed
since he got that permanent badge you
know but at the same time he's
definitely not far-right he's not he's
not a fascist he's not yeah not anything
like certainly people in this day and
age you just appreciate comedy humor
free speech discussing different ideas
they're forced in their push to being in
this bizarre sphere amalgamation of
men's rights activists anti sjw's
conservatives libertarians classical
liberals everyone who's been just forced
to support each other's free speech
together
and in some cases support the far less
free speech as well despite the fact
that they want to take all of ours away
now one more thing here I wanted to ask
you about there's this March for men
that is taking place in Australia and it
has you all up in arms can you tell me a
little bit about that I don't know much
um it's being organized by a woman named
Sydney Watson who has a YouTube channel
yeah it's she's not super super popular
like she's doesn't not in the millions
of subscribers or anything but but she's
got a good head on her shoulders she's
conservative she she's quite similar to
you and her views and she like recently
there was a young woman killed Eurydice
Dixon who was raped and murdered while
walking home from work at night and ever
since then it's just been this constant
barrage in the media and in politics in
Parliament of calling all men to task
over the behavior of those few men who
do things like that and painting all of
masculinity as responsible for this and
then essentially saying well women
shouldn't have to learn how to protect
themselves men need to stop raping and
killing us right as if all men do this
and so she she kind of got sick of it so
she decided she was gonna have a March
for men and of course all of the
rhetoric now is about how she's all
right she's she's a fascist she's a
misogynist she's this March for men full
Stoff Morris full stop March for men is
racist right because I guess because
white men are included in that category
and anything that includes white men as
racists right so and and I'm just
watching this go down and she just seems
like that one of the most solid people
she gave a solid pitch she essentially
said
and men should not be at each other's
throats we are stuck with each other we
need to learn how to love one another
work together cooperate have each
other's backs this is not a march to
slam women this is not a March that's
political in any way everybody is
welcome men women of all political
stripes just to support men just to show
that men matter it's crazy I am a
feminist March in the UK and before I
got kicked out and they started
screaming at my cameraman because they
said no men on the March no men on the
March so not only was it a March only
for women no one had a problem yeah that
of course they wouldn't even let men
March with them and screamed and
attacked men who came near the March to
try and support it or to film it so the
radio silence on that and yet this poor
girl who's organizing a men's march
absolutely yeah and and on top of that
there's a counter protest planned
between essentially Australia's antiva
and some other feminist groups the
National Union of Students Women's
Caucus or something like that a
protesting against like men have issues
too they have high suicide rates like
massive and they're more likely to be
killed on on the job
look it I saw it was almost parity like
I'm sure you saw it too and the UN
women's page on Facebook they posted
something where it was like 17% of
journalists killed are women this is a
disaster we have to face this problem
and it address it and everyone's kind of
sitting there like wait doesn't that
mean the 80 some odd percent are men
numbers up we got to get more female
journalists killed to make things equal
right I mean I've seen similar things
like that
you know globally 60 million children of
elementary school age are out of school
half of them are girls well no duh
you know yeah we're supposed to care
more because girls are affected and
people do hear more yeah yeah it's it's
sad it's sad but thank goodness we have
people like you sticking up for men's
rights even though it's tough and you
get all the slander but it's good to
have you when I was young and I started
going to the [ __ ] walks before I got
into this crazy world you had my back
and now you have Sydney's back and thank
you so much for that Karen but we got
her on to the next segment so I'll see
you guys later
morning because sorry oh man why would
you do that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the Blake Lively hush
fever saw the shallows this is every
single shot ever swimming was on this
and in real life if she did this with
lose all our air and the Great Wave
would eat her also by the way she
doesn't have better vision underwater
than great my truck no everyone show
them you love them quarterblack Garrett
what's what's the Twitter's that qtr
utyos' too long black Garrett yeah they
wouldn't let me they want a hell of a
job there were the TriCaster learning
this news enough we appreciate it used
to be key grip Garrett was always a
little bit of a thorn in my side because
he was a smartass you know you smoked
too much mostly I did and of course
Lauren Southern thank you so much and
stefan molyneux karen strong thank you
we really appreciate next week we are
going to have razor actually radio fist
was going to be here this week yes he
was and I hope not his dad was sick you
to take care of him really looking
forward to razörfist and we I know we
all said Matt Iseman is going to be in
third Sheryl and Benjamin okay and of
course hodgetwins bas Rutten might even
have Brian world Strongest Man I don't
know how they fit him in the studio I'm
so excited I don't know how he's gonna
get to the door I have no idea we might
have to have him was too cute Maddie our
our female editor the only female editor
we've ever had very proud of that
I had awkward in this in the office it
does get awkward in the office sometimes
a sorry Madison or mom he's dressing me
up but there won't be a show Monday
because we are going to be working on
possibly the biggest change my mind who
have ever done we have some hidden
camera stuff to give an example the team
that puts us together that Crowder
confronts that you saw this week that
was months of following this person we
have videos that are months in the
making and then sometimes we work on
them for months
and nothing happens so that's what I'm
talking about the new era of the super
videos here because there enough people
at a lot of paradigm slash Mudd Club
who've joined up and if you can Haiti to
join up we can do that but it's not like
Jimmy Kimmel where I can send out
Guillermo
I am Guillermo I am the Larry button um
I have to go out and actually we might
need to find someone who can do some
prosthetics for disguises so the lot I'm
working on this that's what was it
monster con monster monster Palooza
monster Palooza I'm gonna be out there
looking that sounds really sad what have
you just took me to monster Palooza but
I wore a comic-con costume like an
optimist property awkward what they be
really bad I don't
I think it's a video I'm looking at I
think it's gonna be a lot of them I
think we need to do that something that
would be completely out of place but
would still seem nerdy but they would be
elitist in their nerdom this is what I
would I talked with you about today you
know a lot of times we were looking for
something I'm a thirty thirty-one year
old guy who gives a cramp what I have to
say as far as life advice but it matters
to some of you so this is something that
actually was on my heart this week
because I was watching my favorite movie
ever so all this me to the black lives
matter the democratic socialism it all
spawns from the same evil it all comes
from this idea of shifting the balance
of power simply for the sake of shifting
the balance of powers the foundational
philosophy of the left we all know we've
talked about it's sort of underdog
theory it's known by another word Envy
so one of my favorite films is the edge
as men have you seen and I have not I
have not I want to though i watch the
trailer you keep talking violence I want
to watch it it is a matter of IQ let me
say the reason why is because it is my
favorite film it is not maybe it is my
favorite film period I'll say that
people give me crap about that all the
time but don't go and watch the film
comment here let me know what you think
whenever I talk with someone about this
film well I know that's your favorite
shouldn't it be Godfather shouldn't have
I think Chinatown was a better film by
the way who cares about the quaaludes in
the fourteen-year-old it was a good film
but the edge is my favorite film it
everyone comes back and says yeah it was
pretty good no one comes back and says
no I thought it sucked so this is one of
those ideas where you're conditioned to
not like films I get it through a couple
couple lines in the film that might be
cheesy they're a couple of green screen
sequences that maybe don't hold up today
I think it's at least the most
underrated film of the last
quarter-century and I just found out
that the writer David Mamet is going to
be on the same writer of Glengarry Glen
Ross who he wrote the edgy Untouchables
as a feeling I don't know he brought a
most prolific stage right of our
generation he's written a lot of great
films he's going to be on the show I
cannot tell you how excited I am he
actually came out of the closet as a
conservative with an article titled I
believe it was I don't have it in front
of me why I'm no longer a brain-dead
liberal New York Times I believe it's
where he wrote it that's funny I could
be wrong whose New York magazine but I
don't know exactly where it was so
someone can maybe let me know I don't
have a source for this I didn't prep for
this but it's like I just was my mouth
was gonna enjoy to drink and
that's awkward for people who are
listening on audio by the way subscribe
on iTunes if you aren't for when you're
on the road here's a thing he wrote the
edge long before the article where he
came out as a conservative and this is a
big reason I love the film but there are
tons of reasons to love the film
especially when you re watch it it's one
of those looks like a video game where
you're backtracking there Easter eggs
nearly every single shot almost every
line of dialogue means something but
something that is singularly unique
about this film
the billionaire played by Anthony
Hopkins the character's name is Charles
Morse kind of a spoiler alert here three
two good the billionaire is actually the
good guy and this relates back to the
point I'll be making in the realm of
cinema where the wealthy person is
nearly always the big evil oil baron or
the corrupt Wall Street banker here's
this film where Charles Morse the
billionaire surrounded by artists
photographers and even minorities by the
way one of whom just gets crap of him
all out of a bear way worse than the
revenant Seany
the standout man of character the true
blue character is the old white guy
patriarchy personified Charles more
throughout the film he not only improves
people's lives but he saves them and the
point is that sometimes shifting the
balance of power merely for the sake of
it doesn't take into account who's going
to get the power once the shift is
completed sure some of the worst people
throughout history were powerful so
we're all of the best and if we try to
strip power from people simply because
we perceive them to hold it as we're
talking about now in these articles you
see them with with me too that's the end
game with democratic socialism so if if
you want to strip power just just
because people have it that's that's the
reason well who's going to maintain the
balance of power afterward Hillary
Clinton the me to charlatans the LGBTQA
AIP movement feminists but just because
they aren't Charles Morse something else
in the edge that really stands out to me
is everyone in the film wants something
from this billionaire at every turn
here's a know who to trust here's
another motives it's incredibly
isolating I really highly recommend this
film in it there are a lot of undertones
here that I could get into I will
hopefully I will with David made my ways
on the show but it's really easy to
vilify people of power or perceived
wealth you know why it's easy
because it's a lot harder to look
ourselves in the mirror for the selfish
pieces of garbage that we all are when
we want something from those people well
I don't know it could be cheaper
deodorant while we all vilify Walmart
could be cheaper gas when we vilify oil
companies or safer streets while we
vilify cops you know I've known a few
wealthy people about I've been fortunate
enough to know a few wealthy people no I
am NOT I am NOT amongst them but I've
seen it happy with him happy I've seen
it happen with them people like um I
don't want to you know okay
mark Carey Kevin all people I've seen
with folks tugging at their sleeve
demanding something of them you know
what happens when these people don't get
what they want
who's rich jerk and that's how the shift
of power just for the sake of it begins
it sprouts from the seed of selfishness
I know people who are you going this
because all of us do this the difference
is it's a foundational principle of the
teaching of the modern left to use an
example Kevin this is a real person an
incredibly wealthy I'd like to say feel
fortunate to say friend of mine I'm
always uncomfortable asking him for
anything even though he's offered a lot
you know this guy um to give you an idea
okay let me give you some examples here
I'm trying I'm trying to make sure they
don't reveal identity but I don't really
think they care let me let me give you
two examples there are two videos
completed here louder with Crowder this
team never would have been able to do if
not for this man Kevin lending us his
personal plane I know it sounds tough
people or white white people problems oh
listen yeah the guy has a plane good for
him but you know why he lent it to us
just to be a blessing just to be a
blessing not not only to us but to you
the fans one of them was a Crowder
confronts one of them was the whole
gaffe conference and what because we
there was no way to get out there
commercially and they were they were
over eight hundred fans and that in that
nut mess a ballroom I wouldn't be able
to say he knew that we needed to get six
crew members out to a location we
couldn't afford to do it in time
otherwise we wouldn't have been able to
it was an unbelievable blessing that
he'd peer and if you don't ask for it
with a lot of these people you'll be
surprised as to how generous there it
applies to every
moment of your life really this is how
we tie it back you think of anyone
you've ever really been mad with your
dad your teacher maybe your boss your
mom all people who at those moments in
time we're in a position of authority
over you it comes down to submitting to
Authority sometimes when appropriate the
left wants you to submit to Authority
when it's the right people based on
identity politics not based on morality
whereas yep as a Christian I do believe
there's a biblical basis for submitting
to Authority when appropriate so all
these people almost all the people
you've probably disliked at some moment
in your life had authority over you now
think of anyone on the flip side who's
ever actually really helped you and been
there when you needed it someone who
actually meant to be here so I got your
back bro well what does that mean what
does that mean so one who truly meant it
when they said they had your back could
it have been maybe your dad maybe that
teacher maybe that boss maybe your mom
now magnify that that's just a wealthy
person that's just a big-name actor
that's just a person in some kind of
position of authority who for some
reason you or I or society doesn't like
and because of that we automatically
assume them to be in the wrong why
because we so want them to be in the
wrong that's what's that's what's wrong
with democratic socialism that's what's
wrong with black lives matter with an
tyfa and with the me2 movement it's it's
based on so wanting a specific person a
group to be wrong that we will do
anything we could almost taste it and
that's the foundation of the left today
the point here is really there's nothing
easier than to vilify people in
positions of power or authority or
success that we haven't achieved because
we haven't achieved it it's easier to
just hate the people who have some of
them are bad people of course but it's
even harder to look yourself in the
mirror and be honest as to why you hate
that person is it them is it the idea of
them or is it you so think of this in
your life if you're listening right now
there's someone under whose authority
maybe you've been any even difficult
maybe even given the hard time maybe
even vilifying them maybe you're envious
of them and you don't treat them so well
really out right now I'm gonna give you
a second I want you to think of one
person this is an exercise pick one
person in your life
do you think that person deserves how
you treat them you think that person
maybe has his or her own crap to deal
with you think maybe that person could
use someone to really trust maybe it's a
person with a plane point is it doesn't
matter you've been thinking of you and
we all do this make it right go today
right now make it right or at least at
least make it right moving forward
starting today because the truth is
there are just as many powerless apples
as there are powerful heroes and vice
versa it's human nature I'm not trying
to shift the balance of power just for
the sake of it I don't want to
restructure society based on envy oh I
want to see our more good guys and girls
at the top so you know what the left
wants you to be that guy don't be that
guy
don't be the guy or the girl clawing at
the guy who you envy don't envy aspire
to be Charles Morse and watch the edge
and tell me it's not underrated see you
next week
[Music]
you